now people may not remember all the
personal attacks that Marcia Clark went
through her appearance was mocked her
demeanor was critiqued and during this
whole ordeal
Martha was going through a custody
battle so in a way Marcia was put on
trial herself I'm a prosecutor I'm not a
model I'm not an actress I'm a lawyer
and suddenly everybody's talking about
my hair and my makeup give me your
impressions of Marcia Clark she seems
like a [ __ ]
my hair was permed but I had two little
boys in diapers I didn't want to be
bothered I'm trying lawsuits I'm I don't
i just wanted washing her hair and then
i just didn't have time to go back to
the hairdresser or so i'm blowing
nothing he didn't tell me she was the
only woman in a court full of men and
Marcia says it was used against her
talking about her hair suits skirts
attitude you thought there was oh my
goodness yes we certainly are gonna yell
at Your Honor become hysterical for mr.
Cochran to make that kind of sexist
remark hysterical it's extremely painful
I have to say by Episode six American
crime story dies into Marcia's personal
life a single mom going through a
custody battle a topless photo published
in a tabloid sold out the tabloids and
raising a three-year-old and
five-year-old and being at work all day
and just really braked over the coals I
bet her physical appearance and you know
nobody would ever have said that to a
man you know too tough aggressive
ambitious woman all those things bad
where is your client Sarah Paulson
wasn't allowed to contact Marcia
until she was almost done filming this
restaurant in Studio City California
shut down for the private dinner and the
two talked for hours the first thing I
said to her when we met in person was
sorry about the hair first thing I said
was oh my god I got the voice wrong
because her voice is like two octaves
higher now for she quit smoking if this
case happened today do you think there
would have been more women to stand
behind you and kind of rally for you
yeah I think it would be very different
but then again that's on the other side
we have the internet now can you imagine
if we'd had to try this case with
Twitter and Facebook and instant oh my
god I'm sure your hair would have been
made into a lot of means it would would
have been trending that's so good yeah I
know you know it's not a good way to
tread